now this week the goliaths of wall
street have
met their david the gamestop shares
frenzy has seen a surge
of stock purchases by small investors
leads to losses in the billions
for hedge fund pros but now there's
anger on the online forums where this
rebellion was coordinated
after brokerage apps took action to stop
it
they're placing their bets a group of
small-time speculators not professional
traders
have been coordinating the purchase of
gamestop stocks in online forums
even though the retailer is virtually
broke this has been causing share prices
to skyrocket
at the peak of the frenzy the stock had
risen two and a half thousand percent
from its price at the start of the year
well it played out that those who are
pushing the share prices higher
are on the winning side but those hedge
funds that are
short the stock uh that believe that the
price will be going down
uh are getting squeezed and so the
concern
is that we maybe we end up with some
hedge funds that
have financial difficulties gamestop's
rising share price has already caused
problems for some short sellers
who had bet that the nearly bankrupt
firms stocks would drop in value
now every penny they increase means a
loss for the short sellers
it's not all good news for the
individual traders investment platforms
have started to limit trades on gamestop
putting pressure on the price
whether the social media trade can
regain its momentum is as yet unclear
well let's discuss this with our
financial correspondent ashitosh pandey
who joins us
from frankfurt so we've seen the online
brokerages take action
on this but why they actually felt the
need to do that
uh well uh to to begin with robin hood
which has been the hottest
hunting ground for these uh day traders
all through the pandemic
uh they say that it's to save the
company and
the traders from volatility uh remember
uh the financial requirements for the
companies uh
go up for the brokerages go up uh when
there is so much of volatility
uh for example they have to keep more
money more funds
with the clearing houses so that's one
of the reasons uh that uh
the robbing robin hood uh ceo has
mentioned
so what's the reaction to these
restrictions
been well they've been
there's been a furious reaction from
robinhood users and also
all the other daily traders they feel
that the company is now
changed its sides and it is siding with
the financial elite uh
the hedge funds the bigger financial
institutions so
that's where that's where they are
furious uh
in fact uh they've taken to twitter to
rile against
the company calling it well not
robinhood but
robbing the hood that's how they put it
there's also a concern
from the u.s lawmakers your u.s
lawmakers have
said that this is unacceptable uh
especially given that uh hedge funds are
being allowed to
uh trade but daily traders are being
blocked from making trades and
they were the daily traders have also
sued the company
but legal experts do see that there is
not much that they are going to gain
from it
given that uh these brokerages do have a
lot of powers
uh to limit trading it's all mentioned
in the agreements that the customers
signed with the trade
uh brokerages still another day of
trading this week on wall street
do we know where this saga is going to
go next
well for to begin with uh robin hood has
said that
it's going to ease some of the
restrictions it has in fact tabbed into
its credit line
uh to be ready for the the burst in
trading that's going to happen when
those restrictions are eased but the
broader saga it's very difficult to say
which way it is headed uh
how are the regulators going to weigh
and how are they going to limit such a b
such behavior from daily traders
uh given that this is actually leading
to a lot of bubbles in
assets which are actually deemed to have
run their course
it's and but on the face of it when you
look at it what the daily traders are
doing
there's nothing illegal about it so it's
interesting how the regulators are going
to tackle this issue
we'll keep watching ashitosh pandey
thanks for joining us